Jake you look like you work out
I don't well maybe that's because you
don't have anything that actually gets
you in the mood bike for a long extended
period of time you know what they should
do they should do something with like VR
well vert zoom has actually done that
they've made a bike it's pretty small
and condensed while you're doing that
you'll wear a VR headset it doesn't
actually it's we tried it with Sony VR
but doesn't have to be some new VR could
actually be awesome they said it works
with oculus and then there was something
else that they said it worked with
basically it won't work with the phone
it has to be something that you were
able to tilt with because it needs that
tilt in order to function tracking and
it was something I've actually never
done before and I was I was actually
pretty pretty into it I was working out
pretty good yeah they were like super
basic games but they still like I could
see how they'd want to get people to
work out like the first one I think we
played was like you're sort of a cowboy
and you're just kind of lassoing bandits
as you ride through a city and that was
kind of fun you'd lean left right and
your horse would go that way and
basically the fast you pedal the faster
your horse would go and then you get
close you hold down the trigger and let
go of it and pull a bandit off his horse
right and what they were doing was they
were making the every round of bandits
would be faster so you'd have to pedal
faster so the longer you're playing the
the more you're actually working out and
it was pretty unbelievable after about
five minutes of doing it was pretty
sweaty yeah we did it about 15 minutes
each and I'd say it was it's a pretty
good workout
pretty tough workout the second one the
second game was a race race car driving
and that was the one I thought that was
the most a little bit disjointed for me
still and that's just because you're in
this position where your brain thinks
you're going really fast but your body
is stagnant and
I did end up crashing into walls to see
how it would feel and it was weird
because my body was didn't have any jolt
there was a you know like when you play
a racing game the controller typically
vibrates to give you the impact it feel
there is nothing like that so it's a
little disjointed yeah I think that was
my least favorite of the three
just because it did feel weird like I'd
be pedaling kind of fast and the car
would be zipping through and it just oh
and then you'd hit a wall and it was not
it was very discomforting just
interesting too because there was
actually no bike simulation of all the
simulations we played nothing was a bike
and then finally there was a Pegasus it
is my favorite this is obviously my
favorite - is so good you're in this
beautiful Magic field there's little
bunnies and cute little animals near you
and you're just trotting along as you're
pedaling but if you hit one of the
controllers on the handlebar you fly
your Pegasus spreads wings and you soar
over the canyon looking below you yeah
it was pretty amazing when you first
start to get up and you look down and
you see the whole forest below you I
mean once again the graphics aren't like
super realistic but that's not necessary
what they're going for as they as they
said when we talk to him it's more so
about just trying to get that basic sort
of gameplay hook down and then hopefully
getting people to work out as they play
this game do you think this is something
that you would continue to work I mean
if you got this with this convince you
to work out would you be working out on
a daily basis with this I mean I have to
admit I constantly want to work out and
I have zero Drive so this is something
that I could absolutely see the
potential for is it there yet those are
good questions
they also said something interesting too
is that there was going to be online
multiplayer with all these games and
there was also going to be like a I
think I said what ten dollars a month
yeah so the price structure for this is
it's $200 for the bike now if five games
right off the bat five games if you want
to do it with Sony VR now you you
already have to have the PlayStation and
the Sony VR so it's racking up pretty
quick so the still
isn't cheap but if you already have
those items or you're planning on buying
them this is not a super expensive
addition two hundred bucks is nothing to
scoff at but in terms of exercise
equipment it's it's normal that's fine
in addition to that if you pay the ten
dollars a month which is what I think
they're encouraging you to do and
they're going to continuously release
games and content plus you get the
multiplayer so you can actually race
your friends online or your Pegasus's as
they were and try to compete online with
your friends which i think is what's
going to make this game because the
three minigame are the three games we
played we're fun but I don't know what
the longevity with that is I don't know
if that'll keep me coming back to
exercise but I think with that $10 a
month when they keep adding new games I
think that is something that that could
hook a lot of people yeah I agree it is
a heavy price point though so that's
something that we're just gonna have to
see if people kind of can jump on that
bandwagon I felt it I felt I felt the
heat I got some sweat gland sweater yeah
you get your heart rate up a little bit
and it's exciting to see where the
future holds for exercise and PR
you